ok we're doing a new mission here called
supermarket journey batches journey ok
Josh so much life ok let's do this yeah
yeah yeah our hair maybe I can help you
I heard you talking to the mayor I know
where you can find what you need the
supermarket not far from here is a
market the problem is it was overrun by
one of the raw score gangs they'll kill
yes please look at yet but I know away
through the sewers their care bad easy
trick but you don't look the type that's
easily discouraged interested ah yes I
think I can help all the entrances to
the market are barricaded except for the
one that very few know about and
downstairs talk to the guard the door
bat out drunk to let anyone through if
y'all from a little fiber it's the only
way I can't match Wow is he like tug for
a sec blowing the bridges was the only
thing to do Harry of it that's [ __ ] I
keep pressing that pine I'm not supposed
to let anybody by but I could turn a
blind eye if you could do something for
me but all right I'm stuck here for the
time being guarding this goddamn cake I
can't even leave them a bloody piss so
if you could go upstairs to the mayor's
office and look for a bottle of booze
I'd appreciate it anything will do okay
okay if I'm gonna bloody sit here
waiting for thursday the least that
purpose sure can do is make sure I'm
properly lubricate ya loop ammeter it
yes yes okay cat sanaz bed
I saw it too it's like here
[ __ ] okay it just be crispy answer they
said after they crash bang blowing the
bridges with the only thing to do going
to be four francs that's what I love to
wet man whistles
I can't back on here right yep that I
lon she startled shot okay dad I did it
see I knew that but shut
[Applause]
you like that
remember that can't brown bag
we had a lot of these suckers come at
sup her give her that money to
[Applause]
chat
I get that yet
is that noise why do I keep hearing like
the words of a shadow close that's just
for sure ready ready
[Applause]
holy [ __ ] how do you tell me through the
wall
that [ __ ] gas
[ __ ]
like that [ __ ]
Wow this broomstick is so weak
let's see here
or the [ __ ] of the berm go
[Music]
okay okay
okay okay we did it I did that is the
thing
okay um get out of sellers okay this
thing still running I guess yeah let's
take a look shall we I'll take this
large battery thank you and I thank you
oh thank you
oh thank you
yep
you can do to like get them on here Shay
says that God can surely [ __ ] a lot of
these people up here shut and I'll say
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
chef
yeah you like that [ __ ] that got bloody
real fast that's like this I guess I
guess that's a good now thought that
goes well thank you
I just love as a manager tanks
ah ok let me fix some [ __ ] this is very
important and I like upgrade it
very nice house at the Keck I think it
and I think okay good yeah I can't
skills skills skills my melee skills
need to be even better
and there was nothing yet and firearm
penetration just like a source guy
fear is active
[ __ ] that's kind of nice
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
alright
[Music]
okay guys I'm just gonna have to do this
anima
a lot of money and this we're out not
that get back to the iron skull down
that's like that I dollies not thank you
I can't okay Chet may I like break into
that
[ __ ] looks like the cartel
hey kelas Bob that better I can't tell
ok where is my I came right on through
said I got [ __ ] fried
at can't [ __ ] ass
[Applause]
set
yeah but come on where are you
there's other people here oh [ __ ]
where are they
hey
come on
that God got
[ __ ] I got the [ __ ] that is
yeah it's got a [ __ ] ton of money
ah ah
[Applause]
I got it ya guts up here at you like
that
a lot of exciting stuff got on here hats
Dana thank you they call me the machete
cat
add that gap a lot of [ __ ] smut
ok so that's the game plan out let's say
these guys are there right that Chef you
lasagna Pascal's dogs
all right that's right um ok again okay
[ __ ]
that shet
and as you shake and ate that
alright
I like too far away
Oh
oh yeah [ __ ] pase you're fine
that's how ya get up
cat got
[ __ ] no I need all they snacks camera
the snack get me that snack
just keep getting better
Jesus
I feel like bad
nada
yeah that's [ __ ] bloody alice yet and
they snacks
alright this pistol is defective the
fact that the effective weight 220 to
get that yet okay yes scale scale skills
skills
ok that's ok batch how it what is this
[ __ ] that's a 0
that's at
last one Wade a drought know if we're
covering you damn it
that's sad
to that thou yeah are we done that's it
ok I think that's it baby anyway thanks
for watching and we'll join you on next
time thank you